hello everyone and welcome to the second
game we'll be showing from the champions
chester of uh air things masters
and for those of you who are interested
in why it's called air things it's
because air things is sponsoring the
event
uh not sure what it is exactly uh this
is
basically their website it says see how
air quality impacts top chess players
uh in the world during the champions
chess tour so i imagine it's some sort
of a device that improves the quality of
air
and i'm very interested if after this
event finishes uh to compare
the well the quality of moves compared
to the first tournament to see
if maybe maybe better air really did
produce better moves because some people
say that
you actually can't play better if you uh
struggle to
to get air like like the brain brain
works better so i would be very
interested to see if
better air quality does produce better
games
but maybe something to consider after
the tournament so
we'll see we'll see what happens so this
is a game daniel dubo versus david
tongiharo
from round four of yesterday's uh
masters uh
and this is still the preliminary so day
one uh
let's see what happens as i i i think
this is the best game that was played
yesterday now which is often the case
when
when uh when duval is playing so let's
see what happens here now do both opens
with uh
d4 no he doesn't something again with
the interface sorry about that
let me just refresh that all right
there we go d4 by dupont we have knight
to f6
c4 uh sorry about that that's a double
story about that so sorry about that as
well
so e6 end knight to f3 we have d5 the
queen's gambit declined this on the
board and in the previous game we've
seen that it goes in variation with
knight c3 and bishop to b4 but here we
have g3
dubo opts for a nice um nice catalan
setup so here
d captures on c4 and bishop to g2
making use of this uh wonderful long
diagonal
and now c6 uh black would also enjoy
fiance in his bishop but he simply
doesn't have time
because if a move like b6 is played then
you run into a lot of problems after
knights to e5
and it's not very pleasant to play for
black so after bishop g2 just c6
uh and now do both castles with b5
uh now uh trying to defend the c4 pawn
and now uh a lot of moves are popular
here you can go b3 a4 basically at some
point you want to undermine black's
pawn structure on the queen side double
first goes uh knight to e5
puts pressure on the c6 spawn and now
bishop to b7
gihar defends it and now comes knight
the c3 again here
you could also just try and undermine
the pawn chain but duba
plays the calm knight to c3 it's not a
new move it has been played before
several times
uh we have a6 by black now defending his
pawn once again
and only now duo starts undermining
those pawns on the queen side so b3
c captures we have a captures on b3 and
just
bishop to e7 preparing the castle bishop
to b2
now adobo has fiance both of his bishops
so
very exciting stuff and castles by
guiharu
and now comes knight to e4 now these two
knights are excellently placed
the two of them control a lot of squares
and you kind of want to uh
get that knight away from there and
interestingly dubai already had this
position twice
once again shiro once against stitcher
and both of the games ended in a draw
now
in one of the games tonight the d7 was
played in the other one knight to d5 but
here
guiharo actually captures the knight on
e4 so knight captures bishop captures
and now comes a5 starting to push those
past pawns if black can get
a4 in somehow maybe he can even create a
pass pawn already
and here there is one game where queen
to d3 was played ipato versus eliano in
2015 feed a world cup uh putting
pressure on the h7 pawn
uh duboff does a similar move uh only
plays queen to c2 which
also uh puts the queen on the c file but
pressures the h7 pawn
so it's only now as of move 14 that we
have a completely new game
and it's basically where our game starts
so let's see what happens the h7 pawn is
under attack
uh gehara defends it with h6 we have
rook f the c1
putting more pressure on the c file and
the bishop to f6 now
attacking this knight here and now
knight the g4
and already this is such a poisonous
position that you have to be extremely
careful what you play
you kind of don't want to allow this
trade then maybe
captures captures and d5 comes in opens
up the diagonal of this dark square
bishop
but you also want to be careful not to
place something like bishop back to a7
because then you run
into d5 immediately and all of a sudden
you are
[Music]
in a terrible position because after you
capture the pawn and
not much else you can do here because
then you just allow captures on c6
you get bishop h7 check king h8 and
knight characters on h6
and it will be it will be a miracle if
black can hold this
with with absolute you know uh perfect
play maybe it's possible but
it's so easy to to blunder the position
for example if you play d4
block the the dark square bishop you run
into bishop to g8 it's
game over the queen to h7 is the threat
of checkmate since the bishop defends
that
and if you try something like this then
knight captures on f7 is a beautiful
smuttered mate because the queen covers
the h7 square so a royal fork smuttered
mate
so here of course you have to be very
careful and giharo does not
blunder the game he instead goes bishop
to g5 and now dooble just continues
attacking the knight
f4 so we already we've already seen what
happens if you go back with the bishop
a lot of things can go wrong so here f5
and it is
the best reply uh by guihara now
attacking
two of duba's pieces uh and here uh not
uh playing knights to e5 i'm not going f
captures then g5 so
only the obvious moves the duba goes for
d5 and now
this is complete madness on the board
we've reached the position from the
thumbnail
everything is hanging you can move the
bishop you can capture here you can
capture here you can capture here here
like
what do you play here so uh again a lot
of moves are possible here
f captures uh on a4 is the uh is the
best
reply here just uh getting rid of one of
the attackers this is what guiharo plays
and now you'd expect uh duboff to
capture bag of the piece but no
dubu just goes d captures an e6 and he
creates a beautiful pass pawn here
if he can get f5 in it will be a a
defended pass pawn
so what do you make of this position uh
here it seems
best move for black is h5 uh just
attacking that bishop and uh
force a knight and forcing it away
because you don't have access to these
squares the bishop will just capture it
that way
uh so the h5 would have probably been
best but here akihara plays bishop to f6
and here uh it's a very interesting
position where
black seems to be completely lost but
you know just for fun
feel free to pause the video and try to
win this position with white
while i give you a couple of seconds
[Music]
again the the very cool king the usb
stick if you've missed
the previous video got it from my dad
for christmas
uh really awesome stuff it's not 64
gigabytes it'd be cool you know to
represent the number of squares on the
board it's actually 32 but it's like you
know one king 32 the other one 32
makes 64. so i i guess it works
so yeah bishop to f6 uh and now
congratulations to everyone who spotted
bishop captures an f6 it would seem
bishop captures and f6 produces a
winning position for white because after
bishop captures
rook captures you get queen captures on
e4 uh
you get this beautiful beautiful
position for her white
where it doesn't seem like black has a
move here i mean none of the moves makes
sense you cannot
develop the bishop you cannot develop
the knight anywhere the rook cannot come
into the game
uh you're already threatening to pick up
the rook here f5 is coming i mean it's
just a disgusting position for black to
play
so congratulations to everyone who found
that because dubo uh
decided to go for a different one after
bishop to f6 he actually
decided to play ninth captures on f6 but
now gehara
replied with not the rook captures but
rather g captures on f6 he said okay i'm
going to try this queen captures on e4
and now queen to e7
now everything is nicely defended and
you don't really care about queen g6
check you can easily block it with queen
to g7
so uh i don't know the other position
does seem to be more forcing but i also
would have left
this beautiful bishop no way you capture
with the bishop and leave the knight on
the board
if you don't see a force to win so here
f5 of course now this
pawn is just a monster i mean it
completely
dominates all of black's pieces uh and
here comes
knight to a6 you might think why not c5
opening up the attack here i get
c5 in uh the problem is queen g4 check
and now after
let's say you even offer a trade white
would happily trade and after rook
captures
yes you are down a piece but uh i mean
your position is i mean look at this
pawn the other rook
comes very easily into the game it's
still not at all clear
how black will develop and it's uh no
one plays this with black
so instead guihar goes knight to a6 now
you can even have support for pushing c5
and now just rook captures on a5 it
comes with the price of a pawn
h5 taking away this queen g4 check idea
from duboff
uh and now queen to f3 going after the
h5 pawn so here at gejar defends it we
have queen to h7
and now rook a to d1 makes sense you
prepare a very nice rook lift with rook
37 would come with a double attack
so rook 8 to d8 and now rook a
back to a1 now defending that rook we
have queen to h6
probably with the idea of uh maybe if
the rooks
get traded off you still have defense of
uh the h6 pawn maybe even rook to d2
a nice rook lift is an idea all depends
on what dublin plays duo plays king to
f2
and now rook to d5 here now gihar is
threatening to double up on the d
file so rook captures on d5 and here
uh we have c captures on d5 and this
all produced a completely losing
position for black so once again
feel free to pause the video here and
win the game for duba
while i give you a couple of seconds
it's quite a beauty
so uh for those of you who are able to
do it congratulations on spotting the
the exchange sacrifice and for those who
just want to enjoy the show it's
rook captures an a6 and the point is
after bishop characters and queen
captures on d5
uh there are so many threats here like
this is a threat
just a a nice discovered check and
attack on the rook and after rook to e8
you play queen d7 uh now threaten queen
f7 check followed by capturing the rook
and after queen f8
uh you go simply bishop to a3 so it's a
lot to find but it's
uh you know such a beautiful position i
had to show it now it doesn't really
matter what you played the queen cannot
move because the rook falls
even if you play b4 the bishop just
captures you don't care
and after characters is just a beautiful
sequence uh you can either capture or
even
force a queen f7 check first uh and now
it comes
king h8 check you capture with checking
here check
king here you grab this with the check
king here check
king here you grab this with the check
and now it doesn't matter what you play
you have uh six pawns for black's bishop
it's of course uh completely winning
after this black doesn't really have
uh much moves to play so after c
captures on the five rook captures is
winning uh
but duo first played rook to a5 so he
almost played it but he stopped at the
a5 square
and now he allows a guiharo to play
knight to c5 and get the knight away
from there
however gehara decides to go for d4
he gives up the bishop on b7 and now or
prepares to bring his queen over to e3
so again it's a very
very nice idea and uh i have to remind
you this is a rapid game so you don't
don't have all the time in the world you
have to calculate quickly
uh duba goes for it queen captures on b7
queen the e3 check king to f1 and here
d3 threatening to pick up this pawn and
now for the last time
feel free to pause the video and find
the only winning move for white here
while i give you a couple of seconds
so uh for those of you who were able to
do it congratulations on
not playing something like pawn captures
here
and for those of you who found queen to
f3 congratulations
uh you win this game uh problem is uh
if you go for something like captures
here uh it's not going to yield all that
much queen captures on d3 check and
you're just gonna allow the queen to
continually check your check check your
structure check and i mean
it will be a a a draw by perpetual
checking
so after d3 queen to f3 only winning
move for do both
and now queen to d2 again capturing
doesn't really do all that much
you don't really gain anything for
example captures with check
you're gonna capture with the queen and
there's no continuation here for black
no no useful checks no nothing so here
instead
after this queen to f3 move we have
queen to d2
now attacking the bishop here uh and
here uh
dubu just captures the knight rook
captures on a5 queen captures on v2 and
now queen captures and d3
and now as you can see uh it's uh
it's a funny position but uh do with
spawns are simply too strong especially
the past e6 pawn
so here we have rook the c8 preparing
rook to see one check but
says that's nothing i'm just gonna push
my pawn and even if you deliver this
check i'm just gonna move the king
there's no continuation here no good
checks so after e7 we have rook to e8
blocking the rook
but now rook the e6 dubois is playing
this very carefully a lot of moves are
winning here
king to f7 and now queen to f3 going
after the pawn here so here
uh gehara re-maneuvers his queen queen
c1 check king g2 and queen back to h6
defending it but now queen d5
threatening a lot of nasty discoveries
here king g7
and now queen captures on b5 king back
to f7
now again queen to c4 again threatening
some nasty discoveries after the rook
moves
so here rook captures an e7 but now just
rook to e4 check this is uh
you can win this position a lot of ways
rook to e4 is just the quickest because
here
i'm just going to show it because it's
very instructive for new players uh
it seems for new players it might seem
like this is a chaotic position but for
example
if black plays something like king to f8
you immediately win the game just queen
c5
the point is you uh now pin the attacked
piece
uh and the next move you're just going
to capture it because you have five
points your opponent has to
so if your opponent doesn't want to get
checkmated he has to defend it you just
trade everything
captures captures captures and captures
and now this is a completely winning
king and opponent game so you don't
you don't even have to calculate
anything if you have a position like
this you're up at least
a pawn or two you always have to check
if this works so of course
king f8 is not played by guihar or gehar
goes king to e8
but it doesn't help all that much queen
to g8 to check
king to d7 and now just rook to d4 check
and it was in this position that uh
david anton giharo resigned the game
as there is nothing more to be done here
he's getting checkmated
we're going to show it because i know
you guys enjoyed to see the full
sequence for example queen the c80 check
king to b6 you're going to get rook to
d6 check
king b5 and now a nice beautiful
checkmate queen c4 check
king a5 and rook to a6 checkmate
so now that's the sequence but after
rook to d4 check aguiharo resigned and
what uh what a wonderful victory for
daniel dubov and
i knew as soon as i saw the position
uh there uh let me just rewind that a
little bit uh
yeah here when i saw this move this uh
beautiful
idea of uh f5 and then d5 when d5 was
played i knew this was going to be a
spectacular game
and dubo delivers as always
uh so once again i do hope you guys
enjoyed it uh i would like to thank ryan
goggins avibas patil james chambers jim
stewart and john nelson for a
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot i really appreciate it
as usual you can check two of my
previous videos here thank you for
watching and i will see you soon
continuing the coverage
of the uh showdown checking up on your
wonderful suggestions and whatever else
happens
in the chess world and just in case we
don't show any more games here are the
standings
nakamura leading uh the tournament
alongside eleven aaron and uh daniel
dubo and temura job of all two and a
half points out of four
then wesley saw with uh uh and wesley so
also with two other four so five of them
uh sharing first place then with two
points uh alexander grieschuk magnus
carlsen pentala
krishna and janipam nishi with a one and
a half point uh maximum vashi lagrav
and currently last place with one point
anish giri and david anton giharo
that's it for this video thank you all i
will see you soon and have an excellent
rest of your day